me give me your lounge put your jacket
though
seriously vegan
[Music]
now this moment i saw you last night at
the club totally glad to ask you out
yeah
are you kidding me like the moment oh
yeah that's so sweet
i was actually afraid that you were
gonna be like one of those high
maintenance chicks you know
what yeah i don't know i don't control
freak or
i don't even know god that's so funny
is it is it funny it's funny nah i'm
like i totally just
like to be like easy going yeah yeah i'm
winning i'll be here in five minutes
and we're just now getting our menus
oh i'm sorry don't be sorry be
better right
okay i'll be better that's your job
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so yeah my philosophy is pretty much
like keep it chill
right yeah yeah you know what i like
about you no what it's like
you're not afraid to be like brainy and
respectful
right thanks i really like your boobs
i think we really complement each other
well just did it right there
and uh i pretty much go with the flow
right right and what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you what do you see
there
that's your water down down down
boy then you need okay i have other
tables that i have
what does that look like to you yes
there's a little lipstick on your
glasses
but it mean it's your this is what i
want you to do i want you to take this
class in the back
i want you to break it take the biggest
shard you can find and bring it to me
then i'm gonna slit your color all right
i'm just i'll get you another one i'm
gonna split your throat
and watch you bleed out and i'm gonna
shower in your blood all right
i'll get another water well that would
be great thank you
but as i was saying like i just feel
like it's like do
unto others
it was your lipstick on the glass
what the hell is that what are you doing
wait wait no no no no
oh my god
i just tell you no one's ever
talked to me like that in my life you
have his back who does that it was your
lipstick on the glass
he's just a waiter
you know what take his side i hope you
have a very happy
life together mickey
what's going on right now what are you
doing
[Music]
seriously me again no no megan
you left the jacket hey you left your
check
hey don't do it
i mean i just hurt her feelings and then
she left her jacket at least i could do
something
backward jack don't do it she [ __ ]
needs to [ __ ] she's not needed it's 87
degrees out you know she doesn't need it
in your heart of hearts you know she
doesn't need that jacket don't do it
i think she's gonna need her jacket
she's not gonna be megan you need your
jacket though
seem like a nice guy
are you kidding me no seriously you got
to come back at the bar right now you
come back at night
i don't even [ __ ] know claire yeah
i'm sorry
you left her jacket yeah well why don't
you give it to your new fat uncle
girlfriend all right i didn't even met
her yet
whatever you left your jacket might
throw it in a river why would i [ __ ]
do that i don't care i'm over it
fine
good
me gay give me your lounge cut your
jacket though
seriously me again we start buying
drinks for everybody as soon as she
comes over i mean
who does that you didn't come back to
the bar you're
literally an [ __ ] how is that
possible i can't be an [ __ ] i got
arms and legs and a head
where's my jacket i have your jacket
do you want it no you know what eat it
why would i do that you know what
i'm not following you anymore over it
fine
me can come back to the bar now
now be good
negan do you want your [ __ ] jacket
no seriously come back to the bar
you go back to the bar i'm gonna throw
this jacket in the water oh
nice that's really nice what do you want
me to do me again
damn kiss my butthole okay good fine
fine then i'm going i'm leaving right
now
god damn it
[ __ ] no like seriously your jacket
yeah but it's your jacket though
megan no
i have your i have your jacket
i'm over it seriously me
i'm going to the bathroom okay excuse me
excuse me you get quiet down excuse me
excuse me and excuse me
[Music]
andre where are you shh you sh
i'm looking for my boyfriend what a
chicken girl okay right i'm doing it
right now dude
megan andre vegan
i'm shushing you andre
megan andre megan andre vegan come here
andre negan andre negan andre
megan andre megan andre
siri call andre don't call me
will you facetime me i'm not gonna do it
right now you wouldn't be able to see me
it's [ __ ] dark in here i know that's
why i can't
find you i'm directly behind you turn
around
okay i'm gonna turn around you didn't
need to announce it just do it
i'm right there [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] stop
yelling at me
naked have you sustained a headache or
had a stroke in the last 10 minutes
what do you mean by that me con dude
put your phone yep away yep omg
did you just hang up on me yes i'm not
talking to you sir i'm talking to my
boyfriend
it's me meegan i'm jay
get out of here no you get out of here i
can go wherever i want i'm looking for
my boyfriend
i'm jay come on you can't be honest
andre shut
get off me mr director he's not the
director can you shine this light on the
audience i want to see my boyfriend
let me see something ah the light's in
my eyes
me can get out of the projection booth
don't shush me
you name excuse me
excuse me and
[Music]
excuse me
[Music]
i couldn't find the bathroom
[Music]
can you totally chillax i'm so annoyed
right now
can you like not talk to me for like a
second like that'd be great
that'd be fine that'd be fine by me but
oh my god are you serious this is
[ __ ]
what could possibly be the problem with
letting two more people in
check your girl bro excuse me what did
you say
check your girl uh-uh it doesn't work
like that no one checks me
because i'm not luggage okay so you can
go
[ __ ] yourself megan seriously
two more people are gonna come out in a
couple of seconds and then we can go
in now let me ask you a question what
was it like being in the green mile
he wasn't in the green mile it clearly
wasn't in that movie
what does tom hanks's penis feel like
megan moreover how does it feel when
swarms of bees are coming out of your
face
seriously i'm sorry sucker favorite
movie don't apologize for me yeah this
is nice this is nice you look like
common meets the incredible hulk when
you brought the frankincense to baby
jesus
did they like make you stand outside the
barn because you were too big
or did they invite you in with all the
other animals don't flare your nostrils
at me
do you have any idea how impolite that
is he hasn't moved his nostrils
once since we got here i saw the move
they did not move me they flared megan
they [ __ ] did not move
your nostrils flared more than a
survivor from a boat accident what
he's not even looking in the eyes okay
you know what if you're just going to
continue
to be a little prick you're going to get
your ass kicked
don't touch your me meegan
crazy [ __ ]
totally love my nails right now
it's over everything right now over the
floor i'm over the sky i'm over you
over that [ __ ] back there you're a
[ __ ]
naked seriously whatever
excuse me oh god
hey what did you say what the [ __ ] did
you just say
you guys come back here with your little
itty-bitty
dicks
you best control your lady yep oh excus
control your lady no he doesn't control
me cause let me tell you something
i'm not a remote megan baby can we just
let this go
no i'm talking to the [ __ ] of anarchy
right now yeah you
why don't you all gather yourselves and
why don't you just go
and figure out a way to suck on each
other's leathery penis
hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
it's not even the plural of penis
yeah i'm the queen
of the world yes
i feel invincible like i have
superpowers or something
you hear that all you [ __ ] of the
world i can do anything i want and no
one can
stop me cause you don't have to fight
your own fights a crazy [ __ ]
oh boy
oh
nothing can stop me
so what do you want to do tonight like i
was thinking maybe we could meet up with
amy and brad and like before that we
could go to angelo's and before that we
could like just go
buy vegan i have something to say
i had to say it in person because it's
it's like super important
okay um
i know this is sudden but look i've been
thinking about this for a while
and i know this is something that needs
to happen
i'm breaking up with you cool love it
totally fine with that
really yeah cause i thought
i was i was really worried that you were
gonna be like mad
mad oh my god are you kidding me
no of course i'm not mad people grow
apart it happens it's like
part of life no i'm totally fine like
love it love it love it
um so
uh um you know we we had a good run
uh don't be a stranger yeah can i just
can i ask why why
yeah like what i was like i'm doing some
work on myself and like trying to grow
as a person so i really like appreciate
you know why
yeah um okay yeah that's like
you know i think that you're kind of
like a controlling
person thank you thank you for that
that's nice thank you for that
cool no problem yeah so you know what
your problem is andre
what you keep tabs on people
every little thing somebody does you
have to keep a tab of it
wait i i i can't tell if you're angry or
not i'm not
i'm totally not angry oh no i'm excited
it's good it's just like
you said your piece and i just think
that
i deserve the human decency to save my
peace
right right is that is that not okay
no no no it's no of course of course
you're a controlling manipulative person
everyone says it
i i don't i don't think that i am yes
you are andre
yes you [ __ ]
okay now like you sound pretty i'm not
angry
i'm not angry i'm fine i love it
i love that you came to my house and you
broke up with me
in my space and i'm gonna think about
that every time i'm here that's great
that is so perfect for me it's the best
things around here
where else was i supposed to do it
because you won't come to my house oh
wait here he is
the puppet master is back but i'm not
i'm not no i'm not the puppeteer
you're doing this to me it's true you
won't come to my house you said my
apartment looks like two rats just
[ __ ] it every [ __ ] day oh right
like thank you for that
i'm a [ __ ] thank you i didn't no i
didn't say [ __ ] i didn't
always say am i evil or am i a [ __ ] no
no you're not evil vegan
why are you punishing me i'm not
punishing you i know you broke up with
me and i'm not supposed to feel punished
who thinks like that i don't know i
can't
i'm sorry i'm sorry okay me again i
guess i didn't think it through
well it's like too late now i mean we're
dying no it's not too late
megan megan seriously i just i i i had a
feeling
that i thought was true and clearly
clearly it wasn't true
i'm so confused like are you breaking up
with me are you not breaking up with me
megan i'm not breaking up with you okay
cool so what do you want to do tonight
like i want to hang out with amy and
brad but maybe before that we can go to
angelos
what just happened
you